we are prepared to make you a very
generous offer and we are prepared to
reject that offer
Michael you haven't even heard never
except their first offer what is your
second offer for a second it's just not
makes no sense to say I don't even hear
your first job on here second offer I'm
Gohan to vermanian I'm a professor at
Harvard Law School and Harvard Business
School and I'm the faculty chair of the
Harvard Law School program of
negotiation we're going to watch a few
negotiation clips and I'm going to offer
a negotiation perspective on some of the
Dynamics that we'll see on the screen
what is your second offer
twelve thousand dollars
are you kidding me that is insultingly
low I don't even want to hear what your
first offer was I think in general you
should put a first offer on the table
and so especially as a seller of the
business you should try to Anchor the
negotiation at a very high number and
that's by putting a first offer out
there I'm sure you're scared
probably in debt it's the best offer
you're gonna get
I'll see your situation and I'll raise
you a situation your company is losing
clients left and right you have a
stockholder meeting coming up and you're
going to have to explain to them why
your most profitable branch
is bleeding as much of a buffoon as
Michael Scott is this is a really nice
move so in negotiations there's some
terminology we oftentimes use the batna
is the best alternative to a negotiated
agreement so the bat is what will you do
if you don't reach a deal and equally
important they're bad now what will they
do if they don't reach a deal Michael
Scott does a really nice job of saying
look you think my baton is so bad let me
tell you about your Badness and your
Badness you're going to lose your job if
you don't get this thing done so it's a
really nice uh display of pretty
textbook best practice negotiations has
about
sixty thousand dollars
that's a 5x increase from his first
offer so it does suggest that the Baton
assessment of Michael Scott was pretty
correct in that he has to reflect that
in the next offer that he makes my
client is prepared to settle for 50 of
the marital assets
obviously it's a farce it's a nice way
of trying to defuse the offer that's
being made why only 50 ready
why not a hundred While We're Dreaming
why not 150 so in negotiations we've got
a concept called Zopa zone of possible
agreement when you make a first offer
you can anchor the negotiation in your
favor the Research indicates that it
shifts our perception of where the zone
of possible agreement is in this case
you go to the room and think you can get
50 of the marital assets but when the
anchor is set at something more
aggressive than that you feel like I'll
be lucky if I can get 25 so anchors
shipped our perception what's your
bottom line primary residence 30 of
remaining assets but you not so in
general repeat negotiators have to be
more problem solving with each other
because there's going to be a next round
thank you
Freddie it's a negotiation walking out
of the negotiation is an appropriate
tactic to stay at the table in this
context would signal I'll be willing to
tolerate your antics and you want to be
able to Signal it's just not acceptable
I often get asked should I go to their
office or should they come to my office
I recommend and I know it's not easy but
go to their office it shows some respect
for their time that you're coming to
them they're not coming to you if things
really break down you can leave 65. 85
Ari I'll give you a 75 provided that
after I do my due diligence I don't find
out that you screwed up everything I did
here yes or no
the midpoint of the first reasonable
offer and counter offer is typically a
pretty good predictor of where the final
deal is going to end up 85. that's my
drop dead number not a dollar less I
don't care what you think you know I
think that's a potential problem when
you say things like Drop Dead uh
absolute best and final uh this is
really my limit it does reduce your
credibility for the future if you then
agree to something much less than
I'll need to hire my own team we can
make that work the other firm said
they'd lose a billable hours requirement
we just want you working on the cases
that you're passionate about she's
playing them off each other and
sometimes it's very explicit in my
research I do find that the competition
for the deal or the perception of
competition can create a lot more
leverage than just the back and forth
across the table and this is an example
of that I'll need complete Independence
no supervisor no staff meetings no
backseat Drive you're great because
you're you and Elise early on you want
to think about the broad set of features
of the job your responsibility who do
you report to what does a trajectory
look like pay is important for sure as
you get more senior uh things like uh
elimination of administrative tasks you
know being able to focus on what you
love uh less about mentorship and more
about mentoring those things become more
important in the mix I've been offer
double that amount
I find that hard to believe called to
check I've got offers from Lindstrom
shortage group Summers and Powers
Summers and power strength the number
one firm in Pennsylvania if it's a a
weaker firm you might not want to
mention who it is but you could just say
I've got another offer if it's a
competitor firm or even a better firm
you might want to put that name on the
table give me a few days and I'll think
about it let me think about it
about it I think in this context to say
give me a few days to think about it
that is entirely appropriate consult
with your spouse consult with your
family think about what you want to do
it allows you to shop around some more
now on the law firm side some of the the
lower contenders might have considered
making what I call a shutdown move when
she says give me a few days to think
about it the law firm might counter and
say gosh um is there anything we could
do right now that would make it easy for
you to accept our offer right that's the
kind of thing you can try to do to shut
it down and to get it done in the room
because you're aware that if she leaves
the room she's probably not going to
come back in mergers and Acquisitions
and other contexts if you take a few
extra days the deal can get taken away
from you so in general you want to keep
the deal momentum going
time to think about it
I don't need to it's not a good fit we
just said yes to every one of your
assets because you're basically
desperate you might consider saying hey
I'm about to walk away I think there's
just no deal to be done but before I do
that give me your best and final so to
give them a so-called last look can be
appropriate before blocking away but
sure if there's six or seven
possibilities draw out one or two
they're just non-starters that's
entirely appropriate the way she's
deployed competition and the perception
of competition is really pretty terrific
it's pretty good I brought in the
popsicle account today
on my own hey Ginger did you hear about
this
I gotta go so here she does a pretty
good job of saying look here's what I do
here's what I've done here's what I've
delivered and because of that Freddie
rumson's office has been vacant for some
time
I think I should have it
it's yours
really the thing that gives me some
concern is that she she asked for
something quite reasonable and I wonder
is she under asking is she under
advocating for herself my recommendation
would be being aware of what you're
delivering and then making an offer or
asking for something that's reflecting
the value you're delivering to the
company what's the Zopa in this
negotiation and and ask for it I'm a
little disappointed and maybe this is
just the inevitable given the context
that she's in
you young women are very aggressive
I didn't mean to be in polite she's not
being aggressive she's asking something
very reasonable in the U.S there's
research indicating that women in
General on average are less likely to
perceive situations as being negotiable
than our men and as a result they don't
perceive situations as being
opportunities to negotiate now a further
troubling finding is that there is a
backlash when women negotiate and this
guy illustrates that very clearly on the
screen when he says you know you're kind
of a pain you're being very aggressive
she asked for something she got it
hopefully today she could ask for a lot
more how much is it
thousand six hundred we will give you
ten dollars
now low balling is a version of
anchoring if it's reasonable then it can
be an effective anchor if it's
ridiculous it has no effect and in this
case the ten dollars is clearly
ridiculous it has no effect
are you interested in this ring yes yes
but I can only pay eight thousand
dollars
okay I can let it go for it this is a
bit rushed and so when the guy says uh
well what's your offer to take a little
step away talk to Phoebe come back and
say well what do you think of seven
thousand to me that would have been
appropriate uh to just come up with a
number uh that's when mistakes can be
made the only way to really reset when
that kind of mistake is made is to
change the players Joey comes back the
next day and offers seven thousand for
the ring and they get it done at 7 500
and then he sells it back to Chandler
for that price negotiations is a skill
you can you can really work on and learn
over the course of a career can you
become Roger Federer
um you know probably not with all the
tennis lessons in the world I can become
Roger Federer but you can get really
good and I think that's true in
negotiations as well